[Applause]
I like your
jacket I did it for you yeah well thank
you dressing up for Christmas I love
Christmas we just did a Rockefeller
together do you Do You Love Christmas do
you get into the whole Spirit of it yes
I do I me too yeah but you know when I
was a kid um my stepfather brought home
the first Christmas tree that I had ever
had cuz he had just come into my life
and it was a little aluminum foil
Christmas trees with blue balls and I
thought it was the most beautiful thing
I'd ever seen oh I love that I love that
that memory sticks too how special you
never know see people always think you
have to go big and extravagant but that
little Charlie Brown moment that's so
beautiful I love that yeah well we had
no money or yeah no me me we didn't
either that's yeah so I'm with you but
your Christmas special airs tonight on
ABC right yeah and it's are you excited
I love I love doing Christmas specials
look at all that Talent on the stage oh
it's great it's a great show I was I was
able to put in some of the hits and the
Christmas uh songs and you don't even
know what which one is coming and it's I
like that yeah oh that's really cool to
do because people always want yeah they
always want to hear like the hits as
well so that's really smart I'm I'm not
that smart I've never done that um well
we heard that they wouldn't let you have
puppies that you wanted puppies well
yeah how did you know that they didn't I
know well I like puppies I've got
everything it snows on the on the
audience and there's presents and
there's trees and I thought and little
children the little kids are running out
and Santa Claus everything so he had
everything and I said Gee wouldn't it be
great if we had like a puppy for one of
the little kids wouldn't it be great
let's bring Barry a puppy he didn't get
a puppy we've got puppies look at these
two cute
[Applause]
puppies oh my God can I hold one oh my
goodness this is
spot oh how
old goodness hello oh my
goodness what's your name oh you Barry
this is dangerous I do not need another
dog oh my God everybody I should mention
these puppies are spot and Tiny from the
brixies rescue center and you can find
out how you can adopt them or their
friends by heading to our show's
Instagram stories you're
sweet
hello she recognizes me she did she was
like fa Mandy is her you're trying to
get to my coffee bro no um I hear that
you um actually ended up breaking
Elvis's record in Vegas with the most
live shows right that was great it was
an honor it really was an honor cuz
anytime people think of Vegas you think
of Elvis and all those live shows yeah
and you have trumped him I like it yeah
and you know on that day I sang hound
dog oh did you me singing hound dog why
not and I jiggled around a little bit
like yeah I like it you got to jiggle a
little it's Elvis oh they're like crying
do you want to go run around maybe they
want to run around I don't know do you
want down or do you want do you want
down you want to they going to let them
down let him free let him be free okay
okay ready here we go ready run go have
fun they're going to be peeing all over
this place way ready pee yeah go they're
like this is mine this is mine um so
while they're marking their territory oh
my God they're so cute I really don't
need another dog Berry um but I'm
thinking about it um so you I've
actually celebrated my birthday a few
times on stage it just so happens it
happens but you just did your 80th
birthday on stage right I know 80 can
you believe that it's you know what it
flies by you don't feel your age no yeah
you don't no I don't it's crazy it's
crazy I heard you did something funny
when you came out on stage I did I yeah
I walked out with a walker like
this and then I got to the edge of the
stage and I went Tada it's a miracle oh
my God that's amazing it is it is so
funny though I I'm with you though I
don't I don't feel 41 either I don't
feel 41 you're a baby compared I know
but no but I'm I'm saying though like
when we were kids you know you I
remember being 10 I'd like oh they're
almost dead like you know what I'm
saying like you're you're literally in
your head but like now I'm like it
doesn't feel that way you don't feel I
think you're as young as you want to
feel you know what the trick is I just
don't stop I just keep going there's
always another project and another song
and another album I think if you slow
down you're going to stop and I'm not
about to stop and why you love it it's
music and you love it yeah I I agree
with you is it true that your that same
stepdad got you an accordion did he get
you an accordion is that your first
musical instrument that you got it was
I'm afraid to say yes do you ever play
it on stage because I really want to see
I do I did a little section where I
played um like a virgin and oh my God
right and Born in the USA and it was
just aw awful just awful and if awful
means wonderful yeah I know that's why I
love your personality you're like this
really incredibly talented guy but also
very witty um I heard that your first um
your first job um was actually in the
mail room at CVS like in the
entertainment world I was wow I how did
you land that that's a random job to
land I was lucky I really I was lucky
great job and I met a lot of great
people there and I was the first time I
ever played a big grand piano was in the
rehearsal Hall at CBS
and uh and suddenly everybody on the
floor and everybody knew that there's a
piano playing mail
booy and I became the piano playing mail
boy at CBS oh my I love that all those
people were like that dude used to rock
it like downstairs on this piano and
then you're Barry Mano that's amazing so
congratulations you opened Harmony on
Broadway yeah this has been a long time
than making right yes uh yes it's been
uh 30 years oh my gosh yeah we started
years ago and we we mounted it a couple
of times but we just couldn't get it
into New York but now we did we got it
into New York
congratulations all right well we have a
review here Barry hasn't seen this yet
but we wanted to show him so this expert
is from the New York stage review be
advised not even to run but to race to
this tale of a six-man Berlin singing
group that was founded in 1927 that was
awesome and then we have another one uh
the New York Times which also listed the
musical as a critic's pick said manalo's
vocal Arrangements written with John
O'Neal the Show's music director are
marvelous I mean who's shocked at that
news New York Times yeah I'm like you
would be the one to write incredible
arrangement that's amazing though for
people to see it and love it and like
get people to go yes it's it's a very
very important and very deep show and
very funny oh I love I wouldn't doubt
with you being involved um this is crazy
too did you ever I heard this could be a
joke but did you ride into Playboy for
advice like career advice and what kind
of career opportunity was one looking
for riding into
playo I was a desperate young guy okay
okay yeah I didn't know what to do with
my musical life and so I saw this thing
and Playboy magazine my stepfather I
guess used to buy it and I sent you just
outed him I like it yeah right so I sent
a letter saying I I have an offer to go
on the road with uh with a girl singer I
play piano
uh and in order to do that I had to
leave my job at CVS as the mailboy which
is steady work which one should I do
yeah and they they wrote me back and
they printed it and they said take the
job
outside follow your musical notes oh I
love that and I did I left you left and
you did it I left CBS so really you have
Playboy to thank for
everything I do so I know that you and
bet work together um quite a bit so and
I did she help you promote your first
album well yes she let me uh I was her
music director
Andor and arranger and um we went on the
road together and I had this first album
and I didn't want to leave her and so
what she was very generous she let me
open her second act so instead of her
coming out yeah the piano player came
out and you know you know that was crazy
the audience didn't want to see the
piano player singing three songs I know
that but again were very kind best
audiences were very kind to me and they
let me do three songs uh and it was the
beginning of my performing career wow I
think you're wrong though I do think
audiences love I have um my band do that
sometimes like come in and out I think
they do love seeing artists for other
artists I think that's a big a big thing
well she was great to let me do that and
then you then then I actually did take
off on my own and uh and here I am I
know then she then she was like crap I
shouldn't have let him see I lost my
musical director like yeah you're right
yeah that's amazing so wa never forgave
me but you I love it she's like where
the hell did you go like so wait so no
I'm sure she's happy but like you I
heard that y'all were at a bath house
once was it New Year's in the 70s yeah I
need to hear this story because I heard
at one point you took your suit off what
happened
no it was called the Continental baths
and she got booked there and I was her
piano player and it was a spa for you
know for guys so people are just running
around naked and you're singing well
they had towels you know around and she
would sing the sauce spangle Banos so
they would stand up in the
towels she's funny check out the
merchandise yeah yeah she's bruising the
menu It's amazing it was a great gig for
it was a great gig I heard that they got
you to jump in is that true did you end
up jumping in I did I jumped well they
had a huge pool and it it would be rude
not to join yeah it was New Year's Eve
everybody was happy I you know I did I
have done that as well at an Afterparty
I was bored I was like you know and I
was like this is boring so we all jumped
in me and my B you take off your clothes
like I did not take off my clothes but I
didn't have many on I was in my
20s I didn't have I think it was like a
crop top anyway I I was still in my suit
and tie and I it all went out and I went
in I'm kind of a nudist I don't really
naked doesn't bother me yeah naked
doesn't like when I went to France for
the first time I was so angry I was
famous because like I was like oh people
are going to get pictures so I can't
join but I thought it would be so fun
everybody was just naked and I was like
this is was awesome I was like yeah and
people that are very brave I love naked
love Naked and Afraid oh my God I'm like
what would be your tool that you would
bring I would bring an axe I would bring
an axxe I think that's you get like one
thing right like I give you a bowl you
know and a fire starter because those
people who can't have you ever started a
fire with just it's hard it's hard yeah
yeah I would die yeah not the best girl
scout Barry um so what let's talk about
the Manalo music project let's talk
about that well you know I did that
about I started about 15 years ago when
uh somebody's uh uh one of my doctors
called me and said can you get my
daughter a saxophone and I said why he
said they're running out of instruments
in her high school I said they're
running out of instrument anyway when I
looked it up yes all the high schools
around the country are running out of
instruments the instruments they have
are just old and broken down and so I
made it my mission to try to get musical
instruments into schools that are
running out of them and that's what the
matalone music project does that's so
cool especially like you and I both get
it we didn't grow up with much and I had
hand me down everything you know you you
kind of survived off that and if you
wanted to learn if you wanted any
opportunity you needed people to have
you know you know readily available
instruments or anything like that these
kids are playing these I'm telling you
broken down instruments and they still
love it they love their music classes it
becomes their second family uh I've met
so many I was one of those kids yeah
yeah somebody one of the kids sent me a
a picture of a tuba that we got him and
the tuba was bigger than he was which is
adorable standing next to it yeah and
that's that's the kind of thing that
does the matter that makes you feel good
yeah well go online to find out more
about the Manalo music project everybody
and be sure to watch Barry manalo's a
very buried Christmas tonight on NBC for
hits and Christmas
[Music]
songs
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home